welcome talk--i sting hopefully one
arrives and gets transported that's what
you want everything it costs a fortune
with me so I'm actually the worst person
to invest in a restaurant and I thought
it might be nice to be in this
neighborhood I've never really been down
this far into the financial district I'd
never come down to the financial area
except in the daytime so I'm hoping
there are others like me that might take
the chance and come down and find
something good we've only just finished
the bar we we built the bar we were very
unhappy with it as everybody will tell
you so we redid it all the mirrors are
very old you know we found bits and
pieces of mirrors over two or three
years took over two years till we got
tiles that we liked of a certain kind of
period it sort of art nouveau period but
we actually built the clock we found one
like it and they didn't work right so we
ended up building one similar the
chandeliers that they took about 18
months to build properly
I suppose you know a criticism of me
would probably be and probably will be
that a lot of my places are similar you
know and I suppose to some degree they
are I think if they're all a little bit
different but you know it's like
somebody's got twins you know you've got
twins you see them as vastly different
but from the outside you know they seem
like the same person if I've worked with
these guys a long time since is Chino
and Shane they still despise me but but
they put up with me kind of one just to
do a simple burger and it's a brisket
leg it's not dry aged the bun is a
little different there's the potato
onion roll so the onions
get glaze at the end with some whiskey
I mean I'm sorry scotch that's the sound
of a crisp french fried
whoo so we're gonna make the fogger
Augustin
we got haricot vert and artichoke
barigoule suit green lettuce and foie
gras
I don't really have a grand idea I don't
have a vision or any of those things in
the end I'd be able to restaurant that I
want to go to that's all I do I'd want
to eat at this restaurant you know if
the food is good
it's a waiter doesn't insult me you read
more about luxury more about luxury
always at pursuits that ni pursuits go
on the Bloomberg you're watching
Bloomberg